what we're learning about the plan to
give covet booster shots to most
americans so if you're asking why now
take a look at the numbers in the entire
month of june we had just over 400 000
new covet cases in this country that's
according to the cdc so far in just two
and a half weeks into august we're
nearing two million new cases that's a
lot hospitalizations from the virus are
now at their highest level since early
february and there is a lot of suffering
in this country as a delta variant
infects more people wishing is at the
white house with more on the story wija
good morning to you now we keep hearing
these numbers are largely driven by
unvaccinated americans so how does the
president plan to roll out the boosters
for those who have gotten their vaccine
shots
good morning gail and good morning to
everybody the first boosters would go to
people in high priority groups like
health care workers and those who have
underlying medical conditions but health
officials say eventually everybody
should get another dose citing data from
other countries like israel that shows
the vaccine's ability to fight off the
virus goes down over time
it will make you safer
and for longer
and will help us end the pandemic faster
the cdc is recommending a third shot of
the pfizer or moderna vaccine eight
months after people get their second
shot those who received a johnson and
johnson vaccine will likely need another
dose too but health officials are
waiting for more data the boosters may
be available as early as next month
pending fta authorization you don't want
to find yourself
behind
playing catch up
infectious disease expert dr celine
gander a former advisor to the biden
administration is not convinced a
booster shot is the answer we really
don't think that there's an indication
to change recommendations about extra
doses until we see evidence that there
is an increased risk of severe disease
hospitalization and death due to waning
immunity or perhaps the emergence of new
variants
gander said the best way to boost
protection is with additional measures
like masking and gathering with others
outside and getting more people
vaccinated the president also announced
the government would require nursing
homes that receive federal funds to
mandate vaccinations for staffers
and that he has directed the secretary
of education to use oversight authority
and legal action against governors who
have banned mask mandates in public
schools i've said before
this isn't about politics it's about
keeping our children safe
it's about taking on the virus together
united
the advocacy group families for better
care are warning that that vaccine
mandate for nursing homes could end up
hurting patients if facilities are
unable to achieve the mandate and end up
having to shut down and top scientists
at the world health organization are
criticizing president biden for
preparing to give americans a third dose
of the vaccine when some people in poor
countries can't even get one but the
white house says they have donated 115
million doses to 80 nations and they vow
to keep helping anthony luigi thank you